what does the word millennial it means /
it's overused
I think it's categorical in a way that's
become it's almost lost its meaning we
look at these crazy our k ik industries
and problems and we have a completely
different mindset that we apply to it
which i think is very unique means
independent means krejci optimistic but
maybe a little confused
curious hardworking perceptive young
smart intelligent entitled I'd say is
the first word that comes to mind I hate
that I hate the term millennial I mean I
don't like vast generalizations across
like huge swathes of people there's
tremendous diversity across any Democrat
I don't love the fact that reality TV to
find my generation and that I don't love
the fact that we have so yeah
[Music]